this video was created in partnership
with bill gates using figures and
research from his new book
how to avoid a climate disaster this is
the earth's atmosphere
every year natural processes add
approximately 200 gigatons of carbon to
it
in the form of carbon dioxide methane
and other compounds this doesn't just
accumulate in the atmosphere however
as approximately 200 gigatons of carbon
are removed every year through natural
processes such as
acid rain this means that the earth's
atmosphere is broadly in equilibrium
with carbon sources balancing carbon
sinks
or at least it would be if we humans
hadn't entered the scene
we currently add about five percent as
much carbon to the atmosphere every year
as natural processors do
but while some natural process is
removing carbon from the atmosphere have
slightly increased such as the oceans
absorbing more carbon and becoming
slightly more acidic
carbon is building up in the atmosphere
because of human emissions
we have disturbed the natural
equilibrium this is a problem as the
total amount of carbon in the atmosphere
is proportional to the ability of the
atmosphere to trap
heat the more carbon there is in the
atmosphere the hotter the planet
gets since the start of the industrial
revolution humans have added a lot of
carbon to the atmosphere
initially we didn't add very much as
there weren't that many processes like
factories or power plants
emitting carbon by burning coal but as
the 19th and then 20th centuries rolled
on
the amount we added rose significantly
by 2020 we were adding 9 gigatons of
carbon to the atmosphere
in a single year scientists estimate
that if we are to avoid the worst
effects of climate change
we need to limit the total amount of
carbon that we add to the atmosphere
to less than 1 trillion tons or 1000
gigatons
this is an approximate threshold and
plenty of negative effects will occur
before it is reached
but 1 trillion tons is still a useful
target to aim for
to date we have added more than half of
this threshold amount already
at current rates of carbon emissions
this threshold will be reached
in just 30 years to prevent this
happening we need to have a plan
limiting carbon emissions involves
fundamentally restructuring our economy
and we can't expect to hit this target
with an ad hoc approach
but crucially it can be done we just
need to get on with it we can divide our
current emissions as coming from five
rough categories how we generate
electricity
how we make things how we grow things
how we get around
and how we generate heat and keep cool
first of all how we generate electricity
currently
electricity generation represents around
27 of global carbon emissions
but considering that nearly a billion
people don't currently have reliable
access to electricity
this number will only grow in theory we
can cut our emissions from electricity
generation to near
zero through shutting down polluting
coal oil and gas power plants and
replacing them with firm low carbon
sources such as geothermal
hydro and nuclear as well as variable
generation like
solar and wind in practice this will
need to take place over several
decades perhaps accelerated by a carbon
tax making electricity generated through
high carbon means more expensive
and will need to be supported by
extensive infrastructure spending
if we cut emissions from power
generation to zero representing closing
fossil fuel plants and replacing them
with renewables
we delay reaching the 1 trillion tonne
threshold by
11 years this on its own is obviously
not enough
we need to consider where the other
emissions are coming from
construction and manufacturing accounts
for 31 of all man-made carbon emissions
decarbonizing electricity generation
will certainly lower emissions from how
we make stuff
but not entirely to make cement or steel
you must create a chemical reaction that
produces
carbon dioxide and as we make billions
of tons of cement and steel every year
this is a significant source of
emissions without just shutting down the
construction industry we can't stop
these emissions
but we can certainly improve matters we
can improve efficiencies in the
manufacturing process
reducing the emissions but mostly we
will need to counter out the remaining
intrinsic carbon emissions with what's
known as negative emissions
removing carbon from the atmosphere this
could be done by
seeding algae in the oceans a synthetic
process or planting a lot
of trees it's completely impractical to
counter out
all our emissions but we don't need to
we can certainly make a big dent in the
emissions that we just can't avoid
another sector that seems at first
glance to be non-negotiable is
agriculture
everyone on earth needs to eat and that
necessitates growing food
and that necessitates releasing carbon
in fact as the world's population
continues to grow
and more and more people are lifted out
of poverty we will need to grow
more and more food currently agriculture
emits around 18 percent of our total
carbon emissions the majority of which
comes from two sources
raising animals notably cows and the use
of fertilizer
reducing emissions from the former is in
principle easy everyone should just stop
eating meat and dairy products
doing so would reduce global carbon
emissions by up to 14
but that's not realistic decreasing meat
and dairy consumption
and eating more meat substitutes made
using renewable electricity
is a more realistic way to cut emissions
from food perhaps by
a third decreasing the emissions from
fertilizer is much more difficult
however and
there just isn't a practical alternative
to synthetic fertilizer right now
for the moment increasing negative
emissions to counteract the emissions
from fertilizer
is our best bet transport is the last
big slice of the emissions
pie accounting for some 16 percent of
global carbon emissions
road traffic cars motorbikes trucks
accounts for around three quarters of
these emissions which is a good thing
electric vehicles have been shown to be
more and more feasible and economical
and if we make our electricity
generation low carbon over the next few
decades
this will coincide with the increasing
market share of electric cars and trucks
this will likely happen anyway due to
market forces incentivizing people to
buy more electric vehicles over
oil-powered vehicles but as with
electricity generation a carbon tariff
would accelerate that process
the remaining quarter of transport
emissions coming from planes and
container ships will be much more
difficult
between efficiency improvements use of
biofuels and changing habits
hopefully emissions from the sector
could halve in a few decades
but that's a best case scenario lastly
the remaining six percent or so of
emissions comes from how we heat
and cool our buildings in terms of how
we use energy as individuals
fifty percent of it on average actually
goes to heating or cooling ourselves
between improving efficiencies and
converting our electricity grid to zero
or low carbon
emissions from cooling air conditioning
and fridges could fall to near
zero heating is more of a challenge as
many households burn fossil fuels to do
so
whether that's natural gas or wood or
coal electric heat pumps are becoming
increasingly affordable and with
appropriate incentives could
completely phase out gas boilers this is
another sector that will see huge growth
in the 21st century as global prosperity
rises
and highlights just how important it is
that we decarbonize our electricity
supply
but in principle we can tie its
decreasing emissions to those of
electricity generation
each of these five sectors must be
fundamentally restructured if we are to
avoid emitting
the trillionth ton of carbon it will be
difficult
but it can be done it must be done
and done in the next half century if we
are to avoid
the worst consequences of our own
actions
this video was created in partnership
with bill gates
using figures and research from how to
avoid a climate disaster his new book on
the transition to zero carbon
you can find out more about how we can
all work together to avoid a climate
disaster
in the link below thank you very much
for watching i hope that you enjoyed
this different style of video
and i'll see you in the next one